c'est une énorme séquence d'action énorme dans
laquelle c'est vraiment de très bons effets
ils ont pratiquement construit l'ensemble
sauf pour une partie ils avaient un
écran vert mais le plus bon c'est tout pratique
même la sorcière vole sur des balais tout
pratique ce n'est pas CGI ils sont tous  dans les
fils ou il y a une scène où je
descends du sommet de la montagne, je vais
envisager de ne pas tuer chacun
d'entre vous, puis des sorcières et elles
commencent juste à décoller sur des balais comme quand vous
cliquez sur la lumière et que les cafards se
dispersent  Je veux dire que c'est la chose la plus drôle que
nous ayons à attribuer à Tommy pour ce
qu'il a fait avec ce film, c'est de prendre le
consul très connu en péril
conte de fées et de le tordre et de le retourner
, puis quelque chose de très
inattendu et différent avec lui pour que
ce soit  ce n'est plus un conte de fées pour les petits enfants